hey what's up everyone it's Warren and
today we have some pretty big news about
a new Wolverine entering the MCU
as well as some news about the x-men
Deadpool and new mutants entering the
MCU as well so I'll break down all the
latest news in this video and if you're
not aware I started a new giveaway when
the Avengers in game TV spot came out
I'm giving you away five imax tickets so
you and some friends can go see Avengers
in game when it comes out in IMAX ok so
we all know that the Disney Fox deal is
pretty much all but done by now it's not
completely finalized but it's pretty
much there and when the deal is
finalized Disney and Marvel will finally
be able to use characters that they
should rightfully be able to use such as
the x-men Deadpool the Fantastic Four
and many more and with this people are
beginning to wonder what exactly Marvel
and Disney are going to do with these
new characters in the MCU but we now
have an answer thanks to Lauren Shuler
Donner who has been a producer on every
x-men movie every Deadpool movie and
including the new upcoming movies Dark
Phoenix and the new mutants last night
during the televisions Critics
Association winter press tour she shed
some light on what's to happen she
confirmed that after dark Phoenix and
the new mutants Disney will be in charge
of the x-men 100% in Kevin Feige will
have complete control over the franchise
she stated Kevin and I started the first
movie he worked for me he has a great
story sense when it comes to weaving
each world together I trust him and I
trust where he will take it I don't know
what Kevin is thinking I think he's
still dealing with the wealth of
characters and trying to make sense of
it all she then goes on to say that Hugh
Jackman is done as Wolverine for now at
least
when asked if Marvel will begin to
search for a new younger actor to take
up the mantle of Wolverine she said yes
because Hugh just the physicality of it
all just to bulk up this man worked so
hard to bulk up would get up at 4:00 in
the morning to bulk and eat protein
meals every two hours because his
natural state they used to call him worm
when he was a kid so his natural state
is a very skinny guy once you reach a
certain age the body just won't go
anymore I think he was wise to say I'm
at that point I can't do it now that
doesn't mean he can't come back as an
older Wolverine you never
future Wolverine you never know so Hugh
Jackman is done as Wolverine and Marvel
will begin soon to search for a new
younger actor to take on the role this
was to be expected Marvel's going to do
their own take in the MCU for all of the
new characters that they're getting from
Fox a lot of people have mentioned
they'd like to see Ken Reeves play
Wolverine or Zac Efron play Wolverine
but Kevin Feige did an amazing job with
all of the Avengers so I think he's got
a pretty good handle on it then when she
was asked about x-men spin-off such as
gambit and x4 she said that is up to
Disney that really is up to Disney I
hope they will see the light of day but
that's up to them the problem is you
can't have too many Marvel x-men
superhero movies out there because we
will cancel each other out each one has
to be distinctive and yet you've got the
Avengers to follow through you've got so
many distinctive story canons to follow
through and yet we want new ones but I
don't think you can have more than four
four is a lot because people are going
to get sick of them so we have to be
careful he has to be careful of course
he at the end is Kevin Feige and then
the last thing she talked about was the
possibility of the new mutants appearing
on Hulu and not getting a theatrical
release and she said they worked hard on
it I want to see it release theatrically
I'd hate to see it thrown at Hulu so
there you have it we're getting a new
over een that's going to appear in the
MCU when the Disney Fox deal is done as
well as probably a lot of new cast
members for all of the x-men roles as
well and hopefully we still get the
x-force and gambit spin-offs so that's
it for all the latest news we will be
getting a new wool Vereen in the MCU let
me know in the comments down below who
you think would be the perfect actor to
play Wolverine and don't forget to
subscribe comment down below and like
the video so you can enter the giveaway
and stay up to date on everything Marvel
as always thank you all so much for
watching Wolf Wolf
[Music]